I I think I asked a similar question to
Ben Shapiro do you worry that this style
of presentation can turn you from being
um you know a deeply thoughtful
objective political thinker to somebody
who's just a partisan
hack or partisan
um what's a good word talking head do
you mean with regard to Twitter or the
format of my show in general it was so
Twitter for now let's start with Twitter
for now and can you Silo your
style of communication on Twitter from
being a virus that affects your mind
right
I don't have deep thoughts about the
Twitter component Beyond I think across
all sorts of disciplines this is not the
best way to most effectively solve
problems
and figure out solutions to complex
issues you talk about Twitter now right
now I'm talking about Twitter yes that
being said I think all of us to some
degree have to adapt our content to the
platform that we're using in the same
way that what I post to YouTube is
different than what I post a tick tock
would I post to Twitter is also
different do I think Twitter has been an
unmitigated good for society no
um have I chosen to step into Twitter as
one of the ways in which I get my
message out with the good and the bad
yes and I think that there is a deep
conversation to be had there
I think zooming out a little bit in
terms of what I do and I was hoping this
would come up because I think it's
really interesting
I will often get emails from people who
say two things I will get the you would
have such a bigger audience if you did X
Type emails and usually they are plays
to sensationalism
salacious and titillating content more
pop culture Stuff
Etc
on the other hand it's folks who say
listen what you're doing really isn't as
serious as it could be and it seems like
you could do something more serious and
you should consider doing
deep Dives you know once it was do a
deep dive into Kelvin Coolidge and I was
like nobody will watch that so there
it's not by accident that my show is the
way it is right in an hour I'm thinking
of all the platforms I'm on and I'm
saying okay
I want to do a relatively Deep dive on
the federal budget and I want to talk
about some of the
um political tomfoolery going on within
the post office and I'm going to do a
segment about the wacky rally where
Trump said crazy things and made up
three words and said he endorsed the
candidate who's named it right I'm
crafting that in total to find a balance
between let's build this audience as
much as I can in order to have a bigger
base to get my message out there and
include the more serious stuff with the
hope that there's a little bit of
something for everyone and I'm finding a
balance between those two sides of the
spectrum it's a deliberate thing and I'm
aware that if I were producing my show
50 years ago the balance would probably
be different and it would probably
change again if we didn't if the show
was Audio Only rather than having all
these video platforms it would also be
different but it's a decision that's
proactively made to try to get the best
and most out of the hour that I'm
creating every day well it just feels
like there's an entire machine
fed by Twitter and journalism that wants
to divide people
and the drama of that division
highlighting the the partisan division
the drama of that division feels like
it's a tension with objective clear
thinking sometimes
and so that's the
I worry that there's a drug to it
there's too much fun to mock
ridiculous people
on on a uh on the other side I think
you're right about that and
the fact that that is true
to me supports I've talked with my
audience about you know like the old
food pyramid which I guess was like
wrong but let's imagine that there was a
pyramid that that made sense uh the
bottom bread I think uh like whole
grains maybe I don't remember it's been
a while
junk food is at the very top I'm very
open with my audience
the vast majority of what I do is the
top of that pyramid
and I tell people very openly I don't
consume a lot of the type of content I
produce
and I think it's really important to as
a base be doing critical thinking
epistemology how do we believe the
things we believe
Basics about the world
after that reading history economics
philosophy Etc
after that now we're getting into
current events I would mostly be looking
at consuming
um primary source reporting things like
Associated Press whatever I know
everybody will have a different list of
what counts there after that is when I'd
say indulge in some of the commentary
type stuff that I do
if you find that I'm thoughtful enough
to make it into that but I'm very open
and really what I try to do on my show
often is in being that at the top of the
pyramid tell people there's all this
other stuff that should be forming your
foundation
that I hope you're consuming in addition
to just watching me and I'm very open
with my audience about that what about
the shape the Dynamics the the
characteristics of your audience is
there some degree to which you're
through mocking maybe Republicans that
there's a
there's a lean to that audience and then
you become captured by the audience do
you worry about the audience capture I
worry about it
I'm relatively comfortable that it's not
shaping the program to a great degree
in the sense that at this point I have a
pretty good sense of the things I can
say that will upset what I might call my
core audience you know one of the
interesting things just to briefly go
back to the Twitter thing was those
people who were furious with me on
Twitter and they contacted my
advertisers and some advertisers dropped
me and on and on and on none of them are
actually in my audience none of them are
regular consumers of my audience they
were kind of weaponized Against Me by
people who said hey look at this the
people who follow Candace Owens on
Twitter other than for their kind of
shock value they're not in my audience
and with my core audience I know there
are things I can talk about that will
generate
um
displeasure I guess you could say with
my audience sometimes when I touch the
israeli-palestinian conflict that will
happen
sometimes on vaccines there's a portion
of my audience that is more generally
skeptical of vaccines
um sometimes on some foreign policy uh
issues or you know I I'm not a big fan
of Marianne Williamson nor Bobby Kennedy
Junior's challenges to Joe Biden not
because I love Joe Biden but because I
don't consider them to be the most
serious Challengers I know there's
people in my audience who don't like
that they get they get mad at me about
that and I'm totally okay with that uh
and that tension with with my core
audience so in that sense I don't feel
as though I've had that audience capture
take place but I know it can happen and
I'm very open to to being told ways in
which it may be happening without me
noticing